eu gostaria de fazer um pedido a todos
vocês que estão aqui nesse momento vamos
fazer um exercício de imaginação
imaginem se vocês tivessem um barco no
meio do oceano e de repente o oceano
ficou de mau humor
o vento começou a passar do limite
normal você reduza as belas e mesmo com
essa redução os e não consegue controlar
a velocidade do seu barco
as ondas começa a tomar dimensões
estratosféricas e tem um pequeno detalhe
você é o capitão deste barco e dentro
deste barco tem as pessoas que você mais
a essa situação pode ser vista em filmes
é teatro
mas no meu caso aconteceu
verdadeiramente comigo e eu estou aqui
para compartilhar todo o aprendizado que
eu adquiri durante essa experiência
inclusive essa tá pior tempestade quando
a gente sonha
a gente pensa que o som e são perfeitos
só pensamos coisas boas mas ao
materializar esses sonhos
ele deixa de ser sonho
ele passa a ser realidade ea realidade
não traz só coisas boas
ela vem também com essas coisas que a
gente nem imagina é mais bônus testar
muito até para comprovar essa nossa
determinação
não tinha um verdadeiro sentido
quando eu comecei a sonhar o barco eo
ainda viviam uma vida normal netinha
empresa vivia no sistema e sim em 1992 e
todo aquele sonho era bem bacaninha
imaginava o barco naquela ilha deserta
mas o fato é que à medida que eu ia me
aproximando desse sonho estava notando
que existiam muitas barreiras para
chegar lá mas o mais importante
essas barreiras não me desmotivará
aconteceu um ponto muito importante
também nessa época é porque os 92 estava
negociado ea empresa passando
dificuldades mas naquele momento eu
ainda sofri um acidente e esse acidente
fez com que realmente eu assumisse um
compromisso diferente da minha vida
quero dizer um pouco melhor cada dia que
eu pudesse ainda existir e a partir
desse momento aconteceu uma coisa
maravilhosa eu encontrei uma pessoa
muito especial que até hoje continuam a
minha atual esposa solange e aquele
sonho que eu tinha passará seus passou a
ser um sonho a dois
e mesmo com toda aquela dificuldade a
gente imaginava puxa vida se a gente
sair dessa situação vamos mudar de vida
e ficamos com esse projeto que a gente
não sabe exatamente como começar e aí
resolvemos da em início ao processo e
aconteceu que nós tivemos a idéia de
pegar um carro e começamos a ter essa
sensação de liberdade
passamos seis meses morando dentro desse
carro tinha uma barraquinha a gente
chamava barraca do be onde a gente
queria e começamos a
sentir como é importante nós termos essa
exalar essa liberdade é você não ter
pressão de nada você acorda na hora que
se quiser sair fazer o que você quiser
além de tudo a natureza a partir dessa
experiência a gente projetou o barco mas
puxa vida como é que eu vou sair para
fazer uma uma viagem de barco se eu não
sabia dele já nunca tinha entrado no bar
favela até 45 anos de idade
mas mesmo assim ainda vieram duas
pequenas pequenos probleminhas que na
realidade isso é só uma brincadeira mas
foram duas filhas e do pa
eu estava na minha esposa imaginava do
barco esposa dias maravilhosos
romantismo e com duas crianças então a
coisa complicou mas mesmo assim fomos
adiante e em 2003 março de 2003
demos início a essa nova vida nos
mudamos
fomos para nova zelândia com toda a
família
eu tinha um casal de filhos né meu
primeiro casamento a lívia eo iphan e as
pequenininhas no ano e marina ainda
nessa fase em que você está vendo cada
dia que se passou na nova zelândia foram
quatro anos e meio mas esse que tínhamos
que começar passo a passo e aí fomos
aprendendo a aprender tudo novo
deixamos a família para trás os negócios
amigos e chegar num lugar onde você não
conhece absolutamente nada
então uma das coisas que passou a ser a
nossa rotina era o fato de que além de
tudo do zero e comprei esse barquinha o
pequeno do tibery é as crianças a gente
for him foram deixe nós fomos começando
a vivenciar esse momento amigos que
estavam ligadas à vela
tudo isso foi fazendo e fosse nascendo
essa semente de tão dentro da minha
pessoa
em 2007 veio aí a grande mudança gente
imagina você
hoje nós passamos a vida acumulando
objeto quando você se transfere para o
ensino novo estilo de vida você tem que
botar tudo em duas malas
é um processo de desapego aí é que nós
vamos perceber quantas coisas
desnecessárias nós estamos e esse
desapego e foi fundamental para a gente
essa primeira fase da nova zelândia
porque nos permitiu sentiu que era
verdadeira importante né em 3d acumular
coisas a gente não precisa nós temos
muita coisa que nós não precisamos e
essa viagem nos próprios de ouro várias
experiências mas só para dar um resumo
foram 64 mil quilômetros 35 países que
nós conseguimos visitar e cinco anos e
meio vivendo a bordo do casulo
essa viagem é dos próprios de um visitar
assim lugares maravilhosos culturas
totalmente diferentes
tivemos na tunisiana polinésia e a
gracie e aí você vai enchendo a sua vida
de coisas que você nunca tinha pensado
visto civil foi à televisão uma tarde
diferente quando você está pessoalmente
lá e eu pra poder falar um pouco da
viagem eu tive que escolher algumas
alguns momentos a mais especial porque
senão ia sobrar tempo aqui para os
outros palestrantes
a última palestra que eu fiz foram
quatro horas
bom eu vou mostrar então um lugar que me
chamou muita atenção que é do noivo
alguém ouviu falar de nuku hiva aqui
acredito que não mas no curva fica na
mas as marquises e essa ilha
por incrível que pareça nesse mesmo
momento que aconteceu o que vocês vão
presenciar aqui a história
nós estávamos lá atracados de um lado da
ilha e esse fato que eu vou relatar aqui
aconteceu nessa bahia exatamente nessa
bahia existe um barco em 2011
curado com um casal de namorados também
com aquele sonho de aventurar pelo mundo
e as marquesas e de uma tradição que é a
caça de porco selvagem com os cachorros
é uma coisa interessante e esses preços
caçadores se aproximaram do barco e
fizeram o convite ao capitão para fazer
essa caçada e ele aceitou
meus amigos simplesmente ele não voltou
ea namorada e preocupada já querendo
saber lá vem o mesmo guia chamando a
namorada para presenciar e diz que a
vida o problema quando a namorada chega
lá foi violentada mas ela conseguiu
escapar
e o fato é que isso é um caso o episódio
de cana e cattani palista em pleno
século 21
a polícia deve investigar foram
descobrir as alçadas e constataram que
era as ossadas do alemão
bom quando isso acontece você está perto
né daquele ambiente inclusive né poderia
ser até com com a gente
você ver como isso mexe com a cabeça de
quem tá aventurando neto e tudo pode
acontecer paraíso
além de linda maravilhosa mais essas
coisas podem estados
e às vezes a gente não percebe um outro
fato interessante que aconteceu foi uma
outra ilha essa é nos marcou muito
também porque os amigos tinham falado da
ilha e falaram que era muito lindo mas
tinha assim não sabia se tinha gente
morando há ou não
e essa pilha chamada malpeli em francês
que é mau p ra para entrar nessa ilha já
é um desafio porque é um pequeno canal é
uma lagoa e nós temos 500 com um amigo
porque existe uma corrente muito forte
mas ao entrar o coração batendo quando a
gente passa por esse canal
a gente se depara com uma coisa que não
tem palavras para explicar a beleza e
logo depois encontramos uma surpresa que
é o que a uma única pessoa morando nessa
ilha única uma mulher
rina e isso ela vivia de cobra que é um
coco tirado é secado e esse coco depois
ele é processado e se transforma em óleo
para beleza o tratamentos ela vivia da
pesca e vivia por incrível que pareça de
fazenda de pérola e essa experiência ao
sairmos no outro de nós saímos e
pensando puxa vida no mundo de hoje
talvez a gente tenha encontrado única
ser humano entre 7 bilhões
morando sozinhas vivendo sozinha numa
ilha deserta ainda falou que parece que
vai abrir um negócio no próximo ano é o
seguinte ela vai receber as sombras
então quem quiser se livrar da sombra do
pai passar um mês um programa novo que
ela tá querendo pra otimizaria
bom é é dado continuidade a essa
aventura do pacífico apareceu um outro
detalhe interessante é que a ilha de
palmerston nessa ilha também havia um
navegador né em inglês e ele chegou
nessa ilha simplesmente com três
mulheres criou criaram-se duas linhas
imaginárias e daí sairão três famílias
até hoje vivendo em harmonia
eu acho que ele tem um dna assim do
ceará e civil
mas olha a família e tem gente que tem
os 11 aqui né mas de uma mulher só
mas ele resolveu dividir aí é são 64 na
época que nós fomos lá eram 64 membros
bom vamos voltar então ao grande momento
que nós passamos é que foi a tempestade
eu acho que esse momento realmente foi o
que nos transformou porque exige união
de todos na família até nossas filhas
num momento muito especial
mas foi uma passagem exatamente a última
passagem de nova caledônia para a
austrália
e isso aconteceu em outubro de 2012
quando foi anunciado numa passagem só
vocês terem uma idéia você tem uma
janela do tempo mas aquela precisão do
tempo a cada dia perde a cua acuracidade
de 20%
então se você está no meio do caminho
aquilo ali você começa cada vez mais a
não saber qual é o tempo que você vai
pagar vai pegar e ao chega bem próximo
do nosso destino nós tivemos essa
surpresa um dia antes essa tempestade
entrou uma hora da manhã e realmente o
vento mudou 180graus começou a aumentar
de uma forma muito rápida e era noite
é a gente não consegue ver as ondas
vocês viram aquele som e aí a coisa foi
se intensificando se intensificando e
fomos sentimos que o barco que nós
tínhamos catamarã não era bem o barco
mais apropriado naquela condição era
tarde né
e aí 7 horas da manhã em uma grande onda
e aí a coisa piorou gente porque a onda
ao bater na lateral do barco ela abriu o
casulo porto às sete metros mas ao menos
dois pedidos exatamente na junta
meu amigo na hora dessa a situação feia
e ainda entrando água aí complica teve
tive que acionar o pan é o primeiro
pedido socorro
nesse pan a gente verificou que a coisa
podia piorar a tempestade e quando eu
estava em direção ao rádio para pedir
uma idéia a polícia australiana entrou
em ação e disse que dois helicópteros
estavam a caminho para nos salvar e a
gente tinha a partir daquele momento eu
deixei de seu capitão eu tinha que
seguir as orientações
um dos helicópteros nos encontrou o
outro não encontrou
tive que usar aquela pistola para poder
finalizar para ele nos encontrar
agora olha aqui e helicóptero lá aquela
tensão ea gente nunca tinha teve tivemos
que colocar tudo que tínhamos em uma
mochila muito rápido eu sei que tudo
aquilo ali no final o helicóptero não
pode nos salvar e nós ainda tivemos que
eu tive que enfrentar o grande desafio
foi levar um barco aberto por mais 12
horas chegamos nessa pequena ilha no
começo na parede dos corais e fomos
salvos graças a deus estamos aqui mas eu
vou colocar pra vocês um trecho da
reportagem quando nós chegamos
tá meio ambiente t bone hands
tesselation pequeno almoço
a cop-10 fez campanha carro era atingir
o rei vai ter sexo só sai faz antunes
itunes store total meio quem tudo isso o
gol que dá protestou rip existe nem o
som das trombetas que pague fácil aip ce
rn gault to make edição uma mãe e depois
disso tudo eu pensei o seguinte se nós
sabemos tantas coisas boas nós já
aprendemos tantas coisas boas nós temos
que compartilhar isso é não só na no
material como também na parte espiritual
eu acho que o grande segredo né de a
gente ser de nós sermos um pouco da um
pouco mais sentido à nossa existência é
nós compartilha compartilharmos com os
outros que não tiveram experiência e
essa é uma das razões de a razão
principal de estar aqui com vocês agora
e de ter retornado ao brasil
ah eu quero dizer só uma última coisa a
cada um de vocês que estão aqui nesse
momento podem materializar um sonho
agora não desperdice o tempo a decisão
em dentro de cada um de vocês aqui e
agora vocês podem sair daqui e tenho uma
vida totalmente diferente do que você já
tiver até agora a decisão é unicamente
de cada um de vocês muito obrigado